[音楽]
[拍手]
私の仕事は料理家として
また食育インストラクターとしてレシピを考えて発信することなんですが生まれて
このかたずーっと料理が好きだったかというとそういうわけじゃないんですね
例えば
この野菜
キャベツですね皆さんご存知のキャベツです
次の朝言われた数杯この2つの野菜
えーなんと同じ葉っぱだと思っていました
きたで取れたらキャベツと呼ばれて南で採れたレタスと呼ばれて
ええまあ要は同じ半端だろうと思っていました
とかええええん
しじみあさりはまぐり
はいこれも取れたときの大きさによって名前が違うんだと思っていました
はい出生街みたいなことなのかなぁと勝手に思ってました
極めつけにはこちらはいさんまの塩焼きですね
すだちをキュッと絞って食べにかけたら食べたらおいしいやつですよ
これもご飯で出てきた時になんとあ今日はウツボなんだと
いいました
全然違いますね本当にびっくりするぐらい違うんですが
a
とにかくでも11年くらい前までは本気でそう思っていたぐらいのレベルでした
料理は好きな人が減って私にはもう関係ないことなのでお願いしますと思っていました
はいえーそんな私がや料理ちゃんとしなきゃと
思いを改めたきっかけが結婚と妊娠でした
結婚したらですねなんと私のご飯を食べに帰ってくる人ができたんですね
しかも妊娠したことでおなかの中で違う人が育つと私が食べたもので大きくなっている
人間がいるという実感が起きました
もうこれは変なもの食べさせられないし私も自分で変な物を食べるわけにいかないし
料理しっかりしてちゃんとしたものを食べなきゃというふうに意識が変わりました
なんというかも人の命を預かってしまったような感覚があって
そこから必死に料理を覚えました
やってみたらですね驚きましたもちろんあまりの出来なさに何もし何も知らなさい
驚いたんですがそれだけじゃなくてやってみたら意外と面白いことに驚きました
ん何が面白かったかというとまあこれは今でも変わらず日々面白いなあと思うことなん
です
が料理ってとにかく
感覚がフル稼働することなんですね
季節とか貴音か体調を感じ取ったりとか
食材の味はもちろんですが香りとか
色かたちを見たり感じ取る後はそれが調味料に打ってどう変化するかとか
加熱によってどう変化するかとか
あの時食べたあの味はどんなんだったかなあ的よくを一生懸命たぐり寄せるとか見たり
においをかいだりー
触ったり時には耳を澄ませていると聞いたりとか
もちろん味わって料理にかかわるすべてがですね味覚感覚が頼りで a
もう感覚が研ぎ澄まされるような感じ精神統一をしているような気持ちよささえあると
思います
そしてまあつくるだけでは成立しないですね我をりっ
もちろん食べてもらってナンボみたいなところがあります
家にはですね小学生が2人と保育園の子供が1人3人いるんですが
彼らそれぞれ小学校や保育園で毎月
身長と体重を計って記録してきますはいそれを見るとまぁ今月と先月とで全然違う
ぐーんとせも体重も増えていた
するんですねでじゃあその増えた分は私が作ったご飯によって作られたんだなあと思う
ともう何とも言えない充実した幸せな気持ちになりますし子供だけじゃなくて大人にも
食べてもらった人においしいって言って喜んでもらえたり
利益を出してもらえたりすると
そういうシンプルな喜びがお料理にはあります
感覚がフル稼働することとか
シンプルな喜びをもう自分のまさにこの手で生み出せることとかっていうのはまあ私に
とっては
料理以外にはないことで天あれだけいろいろとんちんかんなことを思っていた私ですが
今となってはもう料理がない人生は考えられないようになりまし
さ
でもですね今日は料理っていいねっていう話はこれぐらいにしたいと思います
料理ていいねっていうことはも他所でもたくさん言われているのでそちらをご覧
くださいと今日はですね
まあ11年前の私のように料理にはどうしても興味が持てませんとかやっては見るけど
苦痛ですとか
そういう気持ちを持っているあなたに向けてお話をしたいと思います
私の11年は同じようでしたのでよくわかります
はい
話を料理を始めた頃に戻したいんですが初めて
市販の麺つゆというものを買った時まあレシピに書いてあったんですねめんつゆ大さじ
1とかじゃあ買わなきゃと思って買ってみたんですかそれもで食べてきた面2の味との
あまりの違いに驚きました
何
でこんなに甘ったるいんだろうと思ってこれ便通じゃないと思ってしまったんですね
で母にどういうわけかと聞いてみたら
母はめんつゆを毎回手作りしていて家の免税の味みたいなものがあったということを
その時になって知りました
私にとって食べたいめんつゆの味はハーフの味だったので私も同じく
毎回手作りをすることにしました今でもそうしています
まあ市販のものを買っちゃった方が楽なんですがそれじゃ満足できないんですね
でそんな母なんですがパスタ麻痺
パスタの日はレトルトのソースを買ってきていました
パスタの日はもう母パスと茹でるだけまあサラダを作ったりしてましたけど
パスタソースはもうレッドループもかけるだけというふうにしていました
村内はですね母もそうそうに料理を切り上げられて
a
ay を開けてみんなで楽しく過ごしていたなぁという楽しい曲があります
じゃあ私もパスタソースはレトルトのものを使おうかなということになるかというと
そうはいかないんですね
なぜなら私が結婚したはだけというのがうちはもうれとるぞのパスタソースなんて絶対
使いませんよという祖父だったんです
結婚して義理の母になったのが料理愛好家の平野レミという人でした
まあもうご存知の方も多いと思うんですが
なぜ冊のレスピの本を出していて
まあご存知の通りメディアで大暴れしている人ですはいもう料理歴も何百年とも言われ
ているような大変な人の叔父にあのお嫁さんになっちゃったんですね
レムさんがよく言うのは
アーちゃんおふくろの味を袋の味にしちゃいけないよってよく言っています
袋の味っていうのはレトルトの
袋とか
冷凍食品の袋とかそういう手作り以外のものも味ということなんですが
remi さんはまあ自分が死んだときにみんなが思い出す
お母さんの味がそんなレトルトのものだったら寂しいじゃないって
しょっちゅう行ってますまあもちろんその気持ちもわかるし
はだけの1になったばかりの私はその責任を重く受け止めてしまって
て自らで撮るともーんパスタソースを使うという選択肢をたちましたそして手作り料理
の神話みたいなものを
盲信してしまったんですね
a そんな感じで料理とか料理感っていうのは育ってきた環境とか食べてきた子とか
周りにいる人の考えとかにとても影響されてしまうことなんじゃないかなと思います
自分がどうしたいかっていうのとズレてしまってこうじゃなきゃいけない
あの人みたいじゃなきゃいけないっていう風に自分を追い込んで時にはそうできない
自分を否定して
しちゃって
それそうやって料理が苦しくなってしまうんじゃないかなと思います
でもですね私が料理を楽しめるようになってつくづく思うんですが
家である料理にこうじゃなきゃいけないなんていう正解は一つもないなということを
思います
作る人が楽しくてそれを食べる人が美味しくてみんなが楽しければそれでいいというか
それが全てなんじゃないかと思います
毎日手作りの数が並んで
栄養バランスもバッチリそれが毎日続くのが理想かと
まあそりゃそうですよね間違いはないんですがまあそれを用意する人が
それを続けなきゃいけないストレスで疲弊していたりとか
せっかく使ってるんだからたら左右系が入って怒ってたらどうでしょうか
体にはいいかもしれないけど何か心には良くないような感じがするし
そんなものを出されても素直においしいなって思えるかどうかわかりません
a
なにをかくそうですねこの中の我が家もそんな状況になってしまっていました
まあ仕方ないんですがずーっと家にてずーっと次のごはんのことを考えなきゃいけ
なかったですね
朝ごはんが終わったらお昼は何を作ろうとか
お昼がやった片付いたと思ったらもう晩御飯のことを考えなきゃいけなかったりして
そんな毎日を過ごしていると料理すること自体
愛ももう食べる事自体も楽しくなくなってしまって
a
本当につらかったですでもですね
ウイルスに負けない体を作ってあげなきゃとか
外に出かけられないんだからせめて食事の時間で気分転換をさせてあげなきゃとか
まぁ無事に家族誰にも頼まれた訳じゃないのに自分で自分を追い込んでしまうという
状況が続きました
イライラしている私がずっと家にいて家族もバッチリを受けたと思います
はい理想通りじゃないかもしれないけど
大きなお皿にドーンと盛りつけてはいやってらしてそれをみんなに楽しく取り分けてお
しゃべりしながら過ごす食卓の方がゾーンといい時間が過ごせるんじゃないかなぁと
思いますし
私が今そのレトルトのパスタな事を思い出した時に母を思い出してすごく温かい気持ち
になります正直
仕事から急いで帰って来て着替えもせずに
パリッとした仕事用のシャツを着たままキッチンに立っていた母を思い出して
それで出てきたご飯がレトルトだろうがなんだろうが手抜きだっただって全然思えませ
ん
そんな大変な時でも私たちのために食事を用意してくれて本当にありがとうという感謝
しかありません
この中で料理をする人がとてもたくさん増えたと聞きますすごく良いことだな嬉しい
ことだなぁと思いますがその一方で環境に知られたり
マリ荘に縛られちゃったりして料理することがすごく苦しくなっている人も多くなって
いるように思います
だからですねまあ料理家がこんなこと言っていいのかわからないんですが今日はもう声
を大にして言いたいと思います
苦しくなるぐらいだったらもう変えられるものに頼っちゃいましょう
はい列島職員でもレトルトでももぅばいつでも手前でもお店のテイクアウトでも
惣菜でも今からみー食事っていうのは
手作り以外でもいくらでも選べる時代になりました
あなたの義務じゃないんです料理っていうのは
ただですねええ
やっぱり料理家としてこうも言いたいですね
誰にも料理は諦めてほしくないです
こうじゃないといけないと思っていることから自分を解放してください
解き放ってください理想があることは素晴らしいしその鳥できることもいいと思うけど
もしかしたらそれは苦痛を伴う幻かもしれないとちょっと思い直してみてください
無理なく楽しく続けられることだけを続けるのが一番いいと思います
お味噌汁を作るだけでもいいしごはん研いで炊くだけでもいいしながられた7切るだけ
とか
お肉焼いて味付けしないしを買って食べるだけとか
みかんの間僕だけでもいいですとにかく
何かしら料理される前の食材を触れてそれを自分のためや誰かのために
ごはんとして用意するっていうことを
できる方法で続けてみてほしいなと思います
そうすることで私たちは本当にたくさんの命に生かされていることに気づけると思い
ます
料理は分別に無理やり好きになることはありません
でも
どんな人でも
一人で来てるんじゃなくてたくさんの命に生かされているんだっていうことを
料理を通じて感じられたらいいんじゃないかなと私は思います
そう言ってもですね何から始めていいかわからないとか
まあなんとなく料理を遠ざけちゃってるだって言う人に今日からでもできるオススメの
方法が一つあります
それが自分の好き月をキッズに持ち込むということです
好きなことなんでもいいです a 音楽でもいいし好きな
映画をかけとくでもいいし写真を飾ったりとか
お酒が好きなお酒を飲める環境にするとかコーヒーが好きならこういう舐める関係する
とか
まあ一番いいのは好きな人をキッチンにズレこんということなんですがまあそれは
難しかったとしても何かしら
好きなものをキッチンに持ち株これが方
人にオススメですちなみに私は今日はちょっとどうしても料理の気分がのらないなって
いう日はもう何もせずにまず
キッチンでビールを飲みます大好きですビール
ビールを飲みながら好きな音楽をかけているとまぁなんか気持ちも楽しく
ほぐれてきて長妻みたくなるんですねそしたらあっ
冷蔵庫にキュウリあったからキュウリ切る買って味噌つけるかってなって自然と手が
動き始めます
そんな感じでええ
なんかキッチンに入ると好きなものに囲まれていて楽しいなとか自分らしくいられる
なんていう場所にキッチンがなると自然とペア
感覚が動き始めると思うのでとてもお勧めの方法です
そうなったときにじゃあこんなものを作ってみようかなって思ったらそのときはどうか
私たち有利月を頼ってほしいと思います
世界中のいろんな料理好き料理じょうずがあなたに向けて自慢のレシピを発信してくれ
ています
どうか気負わずに自分とのマッチングを楽しむ気分でレシピを探してみてください
ありがとうございました